[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
brilliant hello Dom we have returned
good afternoon good afternoon to you sir
what's been going on oh no hey we're
wearing the same um type of shoes today
ah all birds all birds
very comfortable eh I like to stick my
laces in my shoes and then walk around
on them been doing that for years
that's that's it's not uncomfortable
no you have to kind of put them in the
right place like kind of in those little
gaps in your feet maybe on the side
um in your arch in your arch of which
one of my arches in is high and the
other one's collapsed
see that's gonna uh
good at your hips at some point yeah you
you normally leave life through your
hips is that right who told who said
that it seems like a very profound quote
actually read it in that book You Got Me
by Bill Bryson well and some expert in
Hip said that you normally leave life
through your hips what like falling down
the stairs breaking your hips down it
was like you enter through something
well through well you would think it
would be uh ladies you would think but I
don't think it will and then you leave
through the hip which uh in the book it
says it's not actually true but I think
the point
once your hips go you stop moving you
sit in a chair and then and then it's a
slow March to the gravestone so for you
that'll be endless episodes of Star Trek
maybe and then if you were to provide a
tonic for that if you're like well I've
just watched Nine episodes of Star Trek
but I did go up at four this morning
so it's still only like you know it's
not ready for my bedtime yet or it'll be
a tonic to that what we'll do I could
start survive I couldn't because I've
never seen one washer and you love it
the greatest reality TV show of all time
for my money I watched 15 minutes of Big
Brother the other night a new one I was
flicking through and almost I almost got
dragged in you do you do get sucked in
as soon as you know the characters on
these shows isn't it as soon as as soon
as the characters have you then that's
you we watched the original big brother
in New Zealand which have very fond
memories of your wonderful sister would
send you which is aging us now
videotapes of big brother and I think I
seem to remember something else I think
you eventually uh sent her a message and
said thanks for the all all of the
something else but from now on could you
only send big brother because Dom and I
are now addicted we had a weekly catch
up didn't we she would record it for a
week and then ship it over to us and
then we do that's amazing that we're
that's not that long long ago 20 years
20 years but in that time now you can go
on a TV and watch whatever you want you
can go on is any music thing and listen
to whatever you want and do you remember
to go won the original Big Brother you
and I are fans of him he was was it
Craig the Joiner well done Craig from
Liverpool yeah and he was a joiner
wasn't he the lovely guy everyone liked
him he's a joiner big smiley face and he
would always feel really sad when he
would vote someone out this week
um I think I'm gonna nominate
um
yeah and then and then he would be on I
think he was on like morning shows after
that fixing people's anything we would
you know yeah he's the he's the type of
guy that if he was doing a job in your
house you'd be like you want to stay a
couple of extra days and just hang about
maybe watch some TV and
well a long time ago now I was lucky
enough to go to a convention in Telford
Telford of all places Northern Wales and
a Gentleman came over and said uh my
sister right works with Ceramics but
unfortunately I think his sister either
had recently had covid or or currently
at that time had covid and he said my
sister was was going to attend
I can see her name here on this box her
name is Tara Squibb
he said tariffs isn't that a great name
that's two things from my childhood
Sarah yeah was the boxer next door a box
a woman boxer no a dog
what oh a dog a boxer Ryan dark okay
I love human names for dogs
and squib was those little things you
you failed at each other yeah yeah
made is these wonderful gifts here which
I I won't I can't wait yeah I won't
create a spoiler for you but I'm just
making sure you're opening it very
slowly I love it and they come with
their own little stand oh my God my
so here I'll I'll just I'll see if it
was a ceramic of the box of dog Tara
that I grew up next door wouldn't that
be great that'd be amazing the top one's
yours we'll just pass it over
they're lovely things thank you Tara
sorry it's been so long wow isn't that
great look at that now for anyone
listening I'll uh let you know what this
is here it's a pipe pass it back because
I've got mine underneath here's a little
hold on it's getting passed back
right for anyone just listening yeah
it's a pipe I would say 10 inches long
hmm
and uh the actual paint part of it looks
as if it's like uh it looked as if it
would be an acorn or something is it
there's some sort of nut I think it is
yeah oh in fact oh you get a thistle I
think I've got yours yeah I would think
so because yours is a Thistle and I was
that's a Scottish and mine is if you
look inside mine's the color of my
waistcoat so unfortunately you've just
contaminated Yours by blowing into mine
I actually sucked on yours or did you
suck on it lovely ornate beautiful pipes
Tara thank you so much
I would think we can or is it purely for
a decoration no no her brother was there
there's nothing in this box so I'm gonna
throw it this way her brother was there
and he said these are totally functional
oh yeah but and they'd be beautiful I'm
gonna put mine up on the stand here I'm
sucking on Main now yeah give it a
lovely socket hang on that's lovely that
Tom thank you
that is really beautiful Terrace web
yeah
stick up there let's just know
that's lovely that Don what you've done
there it's lovely that isn't it you've
given at an angle oh look
that's beautiful thank you Tara Squibb
of course you can send I've been off the
mic for a lot of this show you can send
anything that you guys want maybe it's
something that you want us to eat for
billion dominate the world or if there's
a gift out there or anything particular
that you want to send you can send to us
at the studio and you'll find the
address in the show notes
which is underneath here whatever it is
whatever you're listening or watching
true
now a word from our sponsor better help
hey Dom you know sometimes you can get
stuck on a problem and you can't find
the solution because you're too busy
looking at the problem you're just gonna
enter your spiral Dom and uh sometimes
you just need some help to get out of
that it can be tough to train your brain
to stay in problem solving mode when
faced with a challenging in your life
but when you learn how to find your own
solution there's no better feeling a
therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or how small and also as we know therapy
can be a little intimate you can feel a
little vulnerable going through the
process but the Fantastic thing about
betterhelp is it can all happen online
so you don't even need to have a
face-to-face conversation with a
therapist if you don't need to you can
do it via phone you can do it in your
own way and you know the intimate allows
people to go through therapy without
feeling so vulnerable about the
experience yeah except exactly so if
you're thinking about doing therapy I
would say better help is a great option
I agree because it's so convenient it's
accessible it's affordable and it's
entirely online when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com onion
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
what's better than finding quality
candidates finding them instantly for a
powerful hiring partner you need indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place don't spend hours on multiple
job sites looking for candidates with
the right skills when you can do it all
with indeed find top talent with indeed
Suite of powerful hiring tools like the
indeed instant match assessments and
virtual interviews oh I love that about
indeed they make everything so easy it's
all in one place because there are
things like instant match candidates you
invite to apply through instant match
are three times more likely to apply to
your job than candidates who only see it
in a search as according to us indeed
data with instant match as soon as you
sponsor a post you get a short list of
quality candidates whose resume is on
indeed match your job description and
you can invite them to apply right away
indeed does all the hard work for you
sponsor a job and boom instant match she
was your candidates whose resumes on
indeed fit your job description
immediately after you post with instant
match you can start hiring fast it's
true indeed knows that when you're doing
everything for your company you can't
afford to overspend On hiring visit
indeed.com onion to start hiring now
just go to indeed.com
indeed.com slash onion terms and
conditions apply cost per application
pricing not available for everyone need
to hire you need indeed
peeling The Onion
William should we do a little bit of
housekeeping yeah
Duncan from Cambridge says if you could
Matrix style upload any skill into your
brain what would it be and why wow
that's a tough one isn't it a matrix any
skill will have a let's dump because
that I mean and you're only allowed one
this is the real pick three no you're
gonna pick eight there's this and then
they could be there yeah and I'd also
like that just one just one just one
just one moment
that's so hard because every time I
think of what I'm saying and then but
it'd be really good to do that but I'm
just going to pick one Dom
and it has to be it has to be you can
pick the skill of I'd like to be able to
Fly Like an Eagle no no it can't be
happening
yeah well you think I think I probably
do have one I would be
a virtuoso pianist Pete I want a t at
the end oh yeah pianist hmm I'm saying
this to my friends the other day even
though a guitar is much more fun to be
playing around with friends because you
can put it in the back of your car you
can travel with it you can swap it
around with people blah blah blah if I
could learn any instrument
and the sound of any instrument I think
a piano is my favorite and being so good
on a piano that you're basically like a
chuo so I would go for that I think you
could still do that it's time to take a
lot of work I'm not saying it won't take
a lot oh no no but I like to work but
but if you could just get it downloaded
that's easier isn't it I will come and
see you in the Radio City yeah you can
introduce me ladies and gentlemen a
little penis go get your hands together
for this little penis here
remember both Dudley Moore and Les
Dawson who were both great pianists used
to always intentionally hit the wrong
note right at the end so yeah you get
sucked into the song and then they go oh
brilliant what about you you're still
thinking no I'll take one I'll go for
um
a heart surgeon
I'd be saving lives seven leaves
something down in the boulevards in the
Avenues
and a long conversation with my parents
one time about
people being Heroes real heroes or
elements of Genius I think we're talking
about genius yeah and my parents were
saying there was this documentary about
a heart surgeon who was consistently
doing heart surgeries on young people
young children and my parents were
saying you know there was a real element
of Genius in him which I obviously said
of course and then we were saying well
can you find genius in other areas do I
mean is there a genius darts player is
there a genius hot dog eater a genius
yeah or is there not it's a strange word
Geniuses yeah what does it mean to you
the word genius
I think is genius someone who is
exceptionally gifted in their chosen
field I mean it's not as simple as that
maybe John can find out in the
dictionary would you say genius somehow
to me
genius carries a little bit of a
genetically gifted in the thing all
right get gifted in a way that you can't
make sense of it's just it's just like
why are you okay so like because they
what the same amount hours as they did
and why is your talent oh that's
interesting maybe there is an element of
Junior hang on John is coming with a
dictionary definition so we have the
dictionary definition of genesis
sorry I know I bet it's Webster's oh my
God I was in Webster's uh no carry on
that's fine all right let's go a genius
is a characteristic of original and
exceptional Insight in the performance
of some art or Endeavor that surpasses
expectations sets new standards for
future work uh establishes better
methods of operation or remains outside
the capabilities of competitors wow
amazing so yeah yeah something original
as well gifted an original in their
chosen field very good
well lovely lovely question there Duncan
here's another one from Dustin not to be
confused with Duncan 2D names like
Dominic or Damian or Damon Double D yeah
it was yeah something like that who says
who's from location unknown and said
regarding Tim Curry movies which we
talked about in a recent podcast I came
across a clip of your favorite Tim Curry
movies and I had to let you know mine my
runners-up are the Rocky Horror Picture
Show which is Billy's number one yes and
Home Alone tune two but my number one
although technically it is a mini series
is Stephen King's It he was equally
hilarious and terrifying now Dustin the
reason why I didn't mention Stephen
King's It of which he is terrifying
playing Pennywise is it's a TV show it's
not film oh yeah not a film well it did
he did say that yeah he did say that but
that I think that's the reason why I
didn't say because he asked about movies
mine was Legend I think no mine was clue
or or what do we call it in Britain
Cluedo right clue yeah I think there's a
few other exceptions to that when I was
in Germany we watched a show a film over
here that is called
Adventures in Babysitting yeah with
Elizabeth's shoe
but over in Germany it was called a
night on the town I was like why
wouldn't you just call that adventures
in babysin and uh when I was younger I
watched the movie called
um oh California man
what's your National and Aston of course
and Brendan uh Frasier and over here
it's Encino Man because we were nowhere
and see nor was no not at all
there we are very good another question
here William and Nicholas from Argentina
Argentina I wanted to ask if you've ever
met a person that's deep into conspiracy
theories I've got a close friend of mine
that's into it and I don't know if I
should try or maybe try not to change
his mind was your opinion are there any
conspiracy theories that you're open to
I would say Sean Aston is quite keen on
some conspiracy theories well we've
mentioned some I'm going to keep it
vague yeah United States political
conspiracy theories where he was like
wow
there's something also do you remember
driving around with the boys last week
and Elijah was saying that he kind of
did some research into the potential of
the Loch Ness monster remember yeah he
said that yeah it's not saying that it
is there
but the they've done research scientific
research to say that something that big
could live there yeah that for me felt
like a little bit of a cop-out well I
don't think well my thing with that is
like Bigfoot well there's no evidence
that we that Bigfoot is there but is
there a chance that Bigfoot could be
there yes you're like well that's kind
of a bit wishy-washy I've got a friend
uh who doesn't believe that the men
landed on the moon
do you believe that Stanley Kubrick
filmed at home yeah well I don't know I
think that's one of the things what is
major major thing that makes him go well
what about that
um I don't know if I've ever really got
into it with them lots of people I think
he says darling
he said if they've been up on the moon
and left all that stuff they'd still be
taking pictures of it and be able to see
it and all that and I I just Googled
very quickly pictures of stuff on the
moon and there is pictures of this stuff
yeah see that's the thing about people
they just ignored that yeah that's the
thing with people that believe things so
strongly is even when you present to
them the facts they go well no and and
if you do believe it strongly he's
taking his shoes off it's a good sign
it's quite hard to change your mind yeah
you know and I I very much respect this
person so you know
there's a little part of me it's like
maybe he's right
that wonderful Thai Buddhist
um enlightened teacher yeah
he said something which I believe comes
from Buddhist teachings but you know
he's he's he made it relatively famous
in his lifestyle where he said if you
can observe anything yeah without a
point of view it is the height of
intelligence if you can just watch
something
and not saying it's this or it's there
just observe it it's that's what very
very smart people do not this not that
it's just happening and it is that's
what it is it's a beautiful thing the
guy who comes over or used to come over
and change the filters in my filtered
water right I think I told you this
story believes in the Flat Earth
so he would talk my ear off about it and
I was listening and listening nodding
along and then I said to him well how
come it can be the middle of the night
in England and the middle of the day in
Australia at the same time and he said
but is it and I said yeah and he said
but is it and I said yeah well I can
call someone we can categorically prove
it we can have someone in England and
someone in Australia but again like you
said he's just like well I'm that's not
the way that I think so I refuse to see
that as a piece of evidence because
there is some stuff that you're like
okay like
um
Elvis is still alive no no he isn't like
like
uh there's planets surrounding other
Suns right 100 years ago we didn't know
that for sure 50 years ago maybe yeah
yeah and now the categorically say yes
yes yes but and I totally believe that
but it's only because of what somebody
told me I can what thou myself the way
that you can work out sure there is a
different time in Australia you have to
take educated people you have to take
educated so I can see how you you could
argue against it well someone said there
is no other planets yeah what do we know
well yeah I know did you see this
morning the new images from Neptune from
that incredible no Oscar Oh Billy you
got to see it I love Neptune oh I mean
because I was going to ask you about it
an extremely in-depth look at the planet
a watery blue kind of marble floating in
space but my question for you but you've
not seen it no so I'm going to retract
the question and maybe see if you have
some answer for it next week is what is
lighting that planet is it the sun yeah
wow because Neptune is a long way away
from the Sun yeah and some yeah and it's
still being pretty much illuminated oh
yeah
like ultraviolet light uh-huh but breath
takingly beautiful I was looking at it
last night for a good 10 minutes oh
still later up don't worry about that'll
be a bit colder though yeah not getting
the heat not getting the heat like the
the ones close in it right right right
Mars very hot planet right if you could
get all the planets
in order right now
I will buy you dinner really well in
terms of relation to the Sun to the Sun
from the Sun all the way out to Pluto
and I'll give you Pluto for nothing
because I don't know if it's still a
planet Mars
nope really yeah
because mine's not closest no
Mercury maybe I don't even know I think
Mars is closest then if you don't
definitely not
Mars Venus I used to there was a way of
knowing it yeah I'm doing it what is it
Mars Venus
Earth
Mercury
Jupiter so you've got mercury in Mars
sweat stuff there okay Saturn
Uranus a not yours but someone else's
Neptune
Pluto what what is the poem you used my
very my very educated mother just showed
us nine planets so you got Mercury and
Mars mixed up no no dinner now how about
just a light snack no really well if you
get it wrong wrong a second place is
last place it's a good point let's move
on right Anna from San Antonio said like
you I was like oh this is about light
year the film bills oh good so like you
I was initially skeptical of light year
considering the Toy Story movies in the
TV series however to clear things up in
Toy Story one at Sid's house we see a
commercial for a Buzz Lightyear toy yep
at the beginning of light year they
explained that it is supposed to be the
movie that Andy saw in 1994. what
presumably the movie that the action
figure would have come from I love that
concept it would be cool to see a
western-style woody movie too my only
critique of the light year movie is that
excuse me the space-time Concepts in it
feel much more like 2022 rather than
1990 oh hello 1994. I love it but it
doesn't necessarily feel like it's the
movie Andy would have seen so Andy in
Toy Story one is watching a TV show
about Buzz Lightyear the astronaut not
the toy is that what the same yes wow
but again it's just he's what he's not
watching a real guy he's watching like I
was watching Star Trek yeah he says he's
watching a commercial for the Buzz
Lightyear toy not the Buzz Lightyear man
in space so I don't know how that really
helps really I need I haven't watched a
movie I've started the whole Hollow
balloon I haven't seen the movie yeah
you do that a lot I'm gonna watch it hey
Dom hey William people don't always send
us emails sometimes they send us
voicemail oh that's true do you know how
to send it speak pipe forward slash the
Friendship onion no oh speakpape.com
forward slash the Friendship onion yes
send us your voicemails well let's uh
let's see what we've got this week hi
Billy and Don this is Lisa from
Indianapolis I was home this week with
my seven-year-old she had to stay home
from school so she got to watch all the
cartoons and we were watching Sofia the
first I thought we had seen every
episode but apparently there was one we
had not yet because two little gnomes
showed up and stole a crown from
Princess Sofia and
when I listen to the voices I realized
it was you guys and it absolutely made
my day and so I wondered if you guys
could talk about how that job came about
and what that was like doing voice work
for a kids cartoon and thanks for making
a Mom's Day a little bit brighter
love the podcast bye
that's very sweet remember that I do
actually what day well good little
gnomes weren't we yeah I actually don't
know how it happened I think it just
someone just asked us and we went yeah
right yeah yeah what do we have to go
and then we went there
and then we did our voices
although you could argue right that it
was the beginning of us realizing just
how powerful we could be in the voice
World Arena exactly because from there
we then did other some other Voice work
I
think
and then the podcast yeah and then
another podcast another podcast yeah
sorry
the Devils came
that's a good one and that's good though
yeah if you guys subscribe to uh audible
you can check out Billy and I in uh
Moriarty the Devils game which is which
is super fun it is nice to invoice where
people ask me all the time how does it
differ from doing
other acting that includes
your body as well it doesn't really it
doesn't I mean you're locked a little
bit closer to a microphone because
they're capturing your voice but you're
still performing with your whole body
yeah the whole thing you have to make
sure it's in your voice you know
sometimes you may play someone who's
very
quiet in the voice Maybe
and there they show things through their
eyes more on the TV but you have to make
sure it's in your voice don't you other
than that I I really like doing it as
well I like it too I think I told you
when I was when we recently took a trip
together I've been listening to the
original BBC dramatized version of Lord
of the Rings with lovely Ian Holm
playing Frodo and his his choices for
The Voice work in that he's so filled
with doubt and Dread and insecurity as
he gets closer and closer to the
mountain not to say that Elijah's
performance wasn't fantastic as well but
just hearing that in a voice is
brilliant it's lovely to go to sleep too
good I actually met the guy who played
Pippin oh a party when the movies came
out and somehow we got on to talking
about what was the most difficult scene
to do
and for me it was when pepins wears
allegiance to the steward of Gondor and
it was for him and all interesting and
he for me it was difficult because we
did a lot of green screen and I had to
walk past Dean McCallum but he wasn't
there and I had to kneel and like I was
just in a and it was just a freaky day
but for him he he said it was really
difficult for him as well I don't know
why is an audio thing but he was a
lovely fella um
didn't someone famous play Legolas in
that in the BBC well the the standout
names in that that you would know or
that people tend to know obviously Ian
Holmes Frodo John the measurer who I
think was was he in Dad's Army yes he's
one of the voices I believe possibly
Aragon Bill Nye
plays one of the characters I don't know
and then
Gandalf is Michael Horton oh who has a
who has a wonderful voice
um if I had to guess just know who was
it that I've read played leglessness not
stuck in my mind
I would guess and I've got this
completely wrong I'm sure I would think
so Anthony Daniels
I think it's wrong you mean in the Ian
Holm one yeah I would think uh I think
that's severely wrong 100 yeah good yeah
Mary in the BBC dramatized version is
quite a posh show because as we know
with Mary out of the four Hobbits he
lives in probably the more exclusive
area of the show he has quite a lot of
money quite well educated he's a little
bit of a little bit of a Dandy you know
and you see a little Dandy elements in
his in his voice work I was going to say
to you before we get onto another
voicemail not too long ago we had a
guest on who um
introduces some very Hot Chili Peppers
remember that I do remember it vividly I
got a cramp in my stomach remember that
yeah you got hot hiccups and we both
were flop swaying and then you had to go
walk around I thought I was going to uh
spew up the chili pepper I know you
don't want that coming through again do
you no but that was really bad cramps
took a while because you we all had our
own kind of 10 minutes of heat in our
mouth and face and it seemed to
dissipate and then like half an hour
later you were like oh hang on a second
I'm really struggling here and John had
a hard time with us oh John came in as a
temporary guest and he couldn't speak
and was sweating a lot and then memory
told us that later on that night he had
explosive diarrhea all over his kit and
he says even to this day that the the
little gap between his genitals and his
bumhole is still nippy yeah and bigger
than it's ever been before he said it
looks like like a chewed Plum engorced
yeah engorged yeah and he he was
struggling in the bathroom to try and
find toilet paper and he reached out
blindly and he was his kid but at that
point it'd gone too far so he just wiped
himself with his cat and they've not
cleaned the cat since then and they've
now started to call her chocolate which
I think is quite nice that's a lovely
name for a cat isn't that lovely but
what I was going to say to you because I
think that you would like this quite a
lot I think you could kind of get tuned
into it I've been taking a little bite
of the chili pepper in the morning and
then meditating whilst it's hot and
stopping when the heat goes away because
as I'm sure you remember you get quite
conscious of your breath during the
chilly thing because when you're
breathing it's hot when you breathe out
it's hot so I think it opens up that
area
I find myself doing quite a lot of kind
of like deep breathing and it's been
amazing for like focus in meditation
something for you to think about I think
that's a good idea done because
sometimes in meditation you need
something hence the Mantra so given a
mantra certainly somebody's told me once
they said it's like taking an elephant
through a a market right destroy
everything
but if you if you give them a tree trunk
to hold in his mouth you'll walk through
the market sure if he holds it sideways
he'll still destroy the market well it
depends on the woods good point give him
something to think about that's nice try
will you try it do you still have some
of those chilies I think yeah still in
the house I'll try I'll tell you what
I'll try it try it I'll get back to you
after I've tried it yeah get back I
don't want that cramp again no no you
don't just take a little bit very very
painful take a quarter of what you took
that time and I know you had said when
you were leaving that day I said are you
gonna give your wife something you said
I don't know if I should did she try no
no did you say Alex this is hot don't
try it no she likes Spacey stuff and I
thought Jack would have like dived in
because he normally would and he was
like nah
well I think you should uh cajole them
into trying it I think if I just asked
Ali she would do it because she really
loves Spacey things yeah and uh she
quite enjoys the unknown yeah give her
the pre-warning of saying look this is
very very hot but uh I had a quite an
enjoyable experience with it I'm going
to make it into a hot sauce stroke
Chutney 200 Clues is doing that for us
we'll give him about 10 of them and he's
going to make any sauce for it I think
he was too traumatized because of the
chocolate cat really
well I sometimes get a little bit
nervous when I'm online buying things
and as we know nowadays you tend to do
most of your shopping online we're not
going to stores anymore so you're giving
all of your bank details sensitive
information sometimes makes me feel a
little bit nervous between my family and
my business life I've got enough to
worry about I need the Peace of Mind of
identity protection but how do I do that
and what protection do I need how do I
know well what you've got to do is check
out Allstate identity protection the
best of identity protection from a brand
that you can trust so much of life is
blogging into our digital lives that's
why Allstate developed an identity
protection product that protects your
digital life just like they do your
physical life with all state identity
protection they'll reimburse up to a
million dollars for out-of-pocket
expenses lost wages and legal fees
they'll also cover money stolen from
your bank account 401ks hsas and tax
returns at Allstate they've been
protecting the things people love for
over 90 years not only will they monitor
to help keep you safe but should
identity theft occur their us-based
customer service identity Specialists
provide expert support 24 7 365 with an
industry-leading 98 satisfaction score
got a big or growing family you can
enroll your entire household on the one
family plan that spouse kids parents
in-laws or for a flat rate that's less
than you would pay for two individual
plans and without the typical age or
residency restrictions of where they
live think the identity protection your
bank provides is enough huh think again
the reality is that most financial
institutions Act only after fraud occurs
rather than preventing it having
comprehensive monitoring and coverage
from AIP will help stop identity thieves
in their tracks before any major damage
is done hey Dom yeah I love about all
state identity protection is how easy it
is to sign up I went online thinking
okay here we go this is going to take a
minute or two it's so fast and then
you're protected online is a great
feeling yeah I love that simplification
so when you think identity protection
think all state identity protection to
find out if your employer offers
All-State identity protection head to
aip.com onion if not get a 30-day free
trial at aip.com one last time that's
aip.com
Billy but if a tree falls in a forest
does it make a sound I don't know well
we don't know either that's not what
we're here to talk about but if 27 000
trees fall in a forest would you rethink
about what you're using for toilet paper
I certainly hope so every day 27 000
trees are cut down just to make
conventional toilet paper that's almost
10 million trees a year just to make
something that's used once and then
flush down the toilet that's where real
paper comes in real makes a sustainable
toilet paper that contains no trees and
instead uses 100 bamboo Bamboo well
bamboo is awesome dorm it's a
sustainable option it's soft and strong
and because it's a grass bamboo can be
continually harvested without damaging
the plant itself lovely and while other
conventional papers are wrapped in
plastic in the grocery aisle real papers
packaging is plastic free and offers
free shipping on all orders real paper
is available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or for one-time purchases
on their website all orders are
conveniently delivered to your door with
free shipping in 100 recyclable plastic
free packaging if you head to
realpaper.com onion and sign up for our
subscription using the code onion at
checkout you'll automatically get 30 off
your first order and free shipping
that's r e e l p a p e r.com slash onion
or enter the promo code onion to get 30
off your first order plus free shipping
so let's stop flushing our forests and
try reels tree free paper real is paper
for the planet
should we have another voicemail Johnny
is there another one John there's one
coming come on John it's from his Camp
he does Billy my name is Connor Conrad
and North Carolina
I've also been binge watching a lot of
the podcast lately
um
and in doing so I thought of a question
for Dom it has to do with the scene in
The Two Towers
when you both are being carried to
eisengard and Mary is pretending to be
hurt or injured and the urakai give Mary
some medicine
my question for Dom was if you could
remember what it was like filming that
scene and what the black gooey stuff
tasted like in that particular scene
um I apologize if this is a long
question and I also thank you Billy for
the last goodbye as it is such a
beautiful song and I cry almost every
time I listen to it have a good day Lads
and thank you for listening cheers
thank you for listening cheers lovely
do you remember that do you remember
that we'll run the back of some urukai
and they poured some
liquid is it I seem to recall that was
was Mary pretending to be unconscious
but he actually wasn't or had he been
unconscious because then people say oh
are you okay all right I'm kind of I'm
pretending that I'm more worse than I am
is that right for what reason
to like throw off the urukai maybe so
they put us down the guy he's fat he's
passed out
and we can Nick off you know I seem to
remember and I think I might have even
asked Mark or uh wonderful friend Mark
ordesky to help us out with a little bit
of research on this I seem to remember
it was flat
Fizzy Pop like a flat
Cola drink mixed with a prune juice
concentrate that's what I think it was
so is that what thickened it gave it the
viscosity I think so can you remember
the taste if you close your eyes and you
think back yeah very syrupy and thick
can you remember I never tried it and I
was trying is it only bee drinking yeah
yeah I never got any penderson menderson
medicine I never got any right yeah it
was a slightly challenging scene for me
because as you know Billy I don't like
my neck to be sticky I know that or
anything no I don't like any part of
like when I was a kid and I would eat
ice cream and my hands would get all
sticky from it dripping I'd be like and
I had an Elven cloak that could make
things itchy so they would put like a
moisturize on it and that would make it
sticky and then the fluff would stick to
it so then getting prune juice down
those creases imagine you came back as
John's cat that would be awful you're
awful right now also I'm sure we've
we've all done projects before where
when they're trying to make you sticky
sometimes they're trying to put glycerin
on you and I just say can you not just
come and spray water on me in between
takes and they said well glycerin sticks
around a lot longer and I said yeah but
it's basically like syrup on it then I
have to deal with it all day in your
neck lining oh
that is just hell for me
anyway thanks was it Connor yeah thanks
Connor thanks very much good question
hey Billy well it's been a while what is
that well let me ask you a question
right it's a multiple choice question
okay if I were to offer you the
opportunity to do a quiz right would you
be a delighted right B non-plus or C
slap me in the face and walk out the
studio I would be a delighted well guess
what what the answer's correct we're
gonna do a quiz it's the correct answer
hello hello
hello how's everyone doing
pretty good what's happening where are
you yeah let's start with is it Ally is
it Ally let's start with Ali Ali we know
your name now it's Ally bills Ali what's
your name and where are you from yeah
you don't need to tell us most people
call me leq see my last name is very
long
um but I am in Nashville Tennessee
wonderful what's your second name
I thought it was the other class in
Harry Potter yeah
is it German because balm is obviously
tree right so what's in Germany Quail
tree
what a lovely tree that's lovely and
then underneath is it Sheila or Stella
my eyes are terrible it's Sheila hi
Sheila where are you from
hey I'm calling in from Portland
Oregon just up a bit from where we are
you would love Poland you know why I
love Paul and the beanie Poland great
coffee fantastic coffee fantastic food
fantastic people that's great I'm not
seeing anything against Tennessee no of
course not but they're known for their
coffee aren't they fantastic but Prince
was from Tennessee was it no no it's
from Nashville no it's not from
Nashville Minneapolis I think
Minneapolis right it's time for I will
take the ring
ladies you're here for a quiz well let's
start with this thing because we haven't
done this for a while what are we
singing do you know the answers to the
questions that we'll ask do you know the
answers
do you know the answers to the questions
that we'll ask do you know the answers
I ended with a flourish there will you
take the ring I will take the ringed
Mordor
um
and Sheila will you take the ring we'll
also take the ring to Mordor but do they
know the way let's find out by asking
questions one at a time ladies just a
pre-warning here and it would be amazing
if you um managed to answer any of these
questions uh illustrious uh producer
John Johnny most of these questions 50
of these questions from quote unquote
the hardest Lord of the Rings quiz
online so don't worry because half of
them billionaire have written the
questions and I would say they're easy
peasy I don't know about easy peasy well
lemon squeezy no you're going to be
challenged you're going to be challenged
absolutely but that's what life is all
about well now how are we doing this are
we splitting into teams we're splitting
any teams dumb uh you close your eyes
closed okay so Billy is going to be team
number
hang on Billy now you just keep oh [ __ ]
all right John's gonna be team number
okay so Billy you open your eyes and you
say what number oh no I've done this
wrong he's done it wrong hold on
who calls your eyes
okay and then whatever number you see
that's who's in your team okay
they're closed I think I saw it
oh I'm I'm sitting up and down but they
don't know what's up and down but um up
and down say the number one or two yeah
right ready top I'm ready okay so I will
be with Team Member One You're With
Sally oh thank you quetzal bound she
loves close we've got this we've
absolutely got this so now I'm gonna
answer ask questions to Sheila of course
you are you will ask questions to Alex
Sheila question one this is from the
hard quiz so don't be too old
I shouldn't be start with an easy one
shall we go on an easy one first right
all right Sheila here we go you like
this show Sheila this is a multiple
choice uh question
what was the name of
gollum's brother
was it feagle
was it
deagle
was it
seagull
or was it Ed Chester nuts
oh I'm gonna go with Diggle
character
fantastic start that was a good one I
think God didn't say seagull
number one well we'll go for other we'll
go for another name no now as you know
Dom and I were stuck up a tree down in
Middle Earth or some time and uh that
was an end a walking tree yes now his
name was Treebeard there is other ants
which one of these is the name of an ant
a leaf leg
B quick beam
three C oh God
[Music]
hairy guy
d
ude
Brian
use your mind use your mind
I'm using it I'm going with B quick
beams
ladies right we're jumping into the
difficult section here
I'm going to go easy difficult easy
difficult wow
that's a blinking roller coaster here we
go Sheila Sheila come on what does Frodo
wish for at the black Gates of Moria
and your options are a thousand olifants
with Gandalf on a white one at the head
of the group
that the ring had never never been found
another in fact see
for no killing to occur and peaceful
fruit or D
I wish we'd never come this far
let me know if you need those again
Sheila that's a b c uh
and is this from the book Thomas this is
from the book this is from the books
can I phone a friend oh wait hold on
what phone a friend phone A friend is
that an option
is that when I can give you a clue are
you honestly gonna phone a friend you're
my friend oh right I will go well he's
got the answers in front of it yeah but
I have to give a clue remember it's been
a while since we've done a quiz but
you're allowed to ask for one clue so my
clue would be
um
it's it's from the book
and
it's never heard
in the movie at any point
or it's not nothing that sounds even
like it is heard in the movie at any
point is that conclude them
no but I'm fine because she's not on my
team sorry Sheila Sheila so you may have
noticed Dom doing a wonderful
impersonation of Elijah words or wagons
and to me some of that sounded like I
heard that in the movie but you didn't
hear this the answer in the movie
it's been a while since I read the book
I'm gonna go with do you want the
options again Sheila do you want any
options again are you good
oh okay options options go options again
hey does Frodo wish for a thousand olly
fans with Gandalf on a white one at
their head b b
that the ring had never never been found
see see no killing
I wish we'd never come this far
okay I'm gonna change my answer to C
she'd always go with your first guess my
wife said that I said our biology
teacher told her that once and she's
stuck by that our whole life trust your
gut trust you got always go with your
first one well William that's a very
difficult question are you ready
I'm ready what book did Tolkien want
published at the same time along with
the Lord of the Rings
what he wanted I'm not saying this
happen but what book did Tolkien want to
be published at the same time as the
lord of rings
a
this silmarillion
B
Adventures of Tom Bombadil see The
Hobbit or D
rings of power
I'll give you them again but just
slightly more and more whispered hey
silmarillion B Adventures of Tom
Bombadil see The Hobbit or D
rings apart
Ally your answer's over to you Ali this
is a tough one it is a tough one we said
it was going to be tough we said it
wasn't going to be easy
laughs
use your brain you use your mind and
create an idea and then try and have the
idea move from your brain into your
lungs and kind of puke it out through
air
towards us I'm gonna say The Hobbit so
that would be see The Hobbit which is in
fact the wrong answer it was in fact
they're so Marillion
grr Tolkien wanted to publish the
silmarillion at the same time as the
Lord of the Rings in 1954 it was not
though and was edited and published post
the first message
thank you in 1977 by his son Christopher
Tolkien well there you have it Ali if
there's one thing you could say about
the Friendship onion you get filled full
of knowledge yes but keep in mind ladies
it's still a tie so there's everything
to play for it now question number three
Sheila I'm going to ask the an easy
question an easier
what was the name of the barman slash
owner of the prancing pony that's Barman
slash owner of the prancing pony was it
Parliament butterbur
lemon ciderwine
ciderman butterfly or John the bastard
repeat the first two I would love to oh
repeat the first two for you
was it a parliament or B Bala man cider
mine what was Cindy again you see side
him and butterfly and D of course John
the bastard right carry on
I'm gonna go with a
is that correct
Alexa
lovely as a Sheila zooms ahead two to
one and may I just say not only in the
book but certainly in the movie when we
work with that wonderful gentleman from
New Zealand he didn't have a lot to do
but he was fantastic remember the way
that he said Masters master master hey
young masters come in young Master very
good one he was good and he had a great
handlebar mustache he looked absolutely
perfect what a great giant bar and all
that yeah and do you remember there was
people like in puppetry and all that and
that's the only thing that ever happened
yeah they must have thought that's too
much work see the four Hobbits looking
up at a very high bar and then walking
past what would be a normal sized human
but Pete had them in these huge
elongated robotic limbs where fingers
could move yeah he don't see much of
them anyway once again more knowledge
from the Friendship it's two on to
Sheila but it's uh Ali's go now Ally now
here's something again we're going to go
at names from the Lord the Rings a Gimli
as you know is one of the fellowship uh
and Kimberly at some point had a dad
now was his dad called
Philly
Keely
glowing
O'Brien
that's Philly Kili glowing
or Brian
of like Brian the dwarf
that would be sea glowing
ah wow there's two each what's
everything they play for as we go into
the fourth questions for Bolton ladies
this is your final question unless of
course you draw or as they say in the
United States tie and then we have a
Thai breaker not a draw breaker yes
that's or a jawbreaker which is a type
of bubble gum absolutely delicious the
lovely Sheila over there in Portland
Oregon here you go how does lobelia
Sackville Baggins attempt to smuggle
several small but rather valuable items
out of Bag End like a thief in the night
is the answer a in the brim of her hat B
inside her umbrella
see in her pocket says or D in her purse
that's a good question Tom hat umbrella
Perkins purse just to give you that
again Jessica
umbrella Pockets purse
I'm gonna go with umbrella
yeah and as a bonus gift for you both
Billy can you just very briefly say the
word umbrella
umbrella wonderful there you go
right now Ali here we go you need this
one it's high can I just stop you for a
minute Ally you need this to tie
remember you've still got a phone a
friend or just a clue for some sort the
guards of ministeris laugh
and Pippin protests when Gandalf calls
him
a just a piece of luggage
B
Tom fullover took
see a very Valiant man or d a dragon's
ass
so the guards laugh and pip and protests
when Gandalf calls on one of those you
can have them again at any time just let
me know
here they come hear the colors so a
this Gandalf call Pippin just a piece of
luggage does he call him a Tom fill of a
took
see a very Valiant man or d a dragon's
ass well you're thinking yeah just while
you're thinking that really recently we
did have someone on who was an expert in
chili peppers and and nesters to eat
chili peppers and at that point I would
describe your entire body as a dragon's
ass exactly the hottest one ever and it
was uh it was quite painful quite a
vivid experience Ali remember you've got
a phone a friend if you need it or you
can just go for it and be a real
Gangster and remember the people the
guards of many terrorists laugh when you
hear Gandalf say this and Pippin
protests
I have an idea but I would like your
help Dom
[Music]
okay well I'll only say this Ali and
nothing else at this point not only in
the books but also in the films
Pippin
has gone through a variety of situations
in which you would probably say is being
a little foolish and foolhardy there but
also a couple of occasions where Gandalf
had to say you know what if he wasn't
here important things wouldn't have
happened I'm just saying he's grown as a
character he's grown in respect and
stature due to his end Draft Drinking
he's been through a hill yes haven't we
all
so I'm just going to say I'm gonna say a
valiant man
wow
Gandalf called Pippin took a very
Valiant man and Pippin protests and says
I am a hobbit and no more Valiant than I
am a man save perhaps now and again by
necessity
now we're in a tiebreaker situation
situation don't worry
this is should we ask them should we ask
them both question nine which is
difficult and we could get an an answer
out the two of them and see who does
well should we do that yeah I mean it's
hard it's very hard do you know this
well yeah would you would you have known
it if you know right this is very
difficult and what we're going to do
I think we just both have them answered
because if they're both kind of buzz in
then we can't clearly tell you no we
can't yeah so both that what if they
both answer the same thing then we'll
ask another question
yeah could go on forever ready ready
okay okay here you go ladies so just
we'll ask we'll ask the question no need
to be a Speedy Gonzalez you can just
answer in your own time yeah here's the
question where
on the map of Middle Earth is the Eisen
mouth the Eisen Mouse is it a between
the mountains of Shadow and the Ashen
mountains
between them
Billy B between the most of the rivers
left Nui and gray floor so see in the
Wizard's valve overlooked by orthank or
D Over the Sea of Tory Beyond The Lonely
grave goodness mate this keep in mind
ladies this was thought to be one of the
hardest questions ever done by the BBC
about Lord rings so eisenmuth yes Eisen
mouth so your your options are between
two mountains
between the mouths of Two Rivers
in a Wizard's valve overlooking orphan I
think that's value sorry about that
value or over the sea Beyond The Lonely
grave
ABC or D ladies
thoughts ladies thoughts you can take
your time in which case mean Dom will
hum
[Music]
I think my thought is C
Ali has gone for question C and she's
locked it in any thoughts you could
obviously answer C if you like or you
could of course do a b and of course d
I'm also gonna go with C well that's
well both are saying in Wizard's value
overlooked by orthank I'm afraid that
right answer is incorrect both of you
are absolutely incorrect it's between
the mountains of Shadow and the Ashen
mountains of course it was done William
asked these lovely ladies another
question right this one's about heat oh
Heat and meadowless
right first off
do you know what a gleed is
g-l-e-d-e this is not the question I'm
just asking you as fellow human being
um as an English an old archaic English
word for a live call or an ember so
something very very hard very very hot
and um in tolkien's book The Lord of the
Rings something was as hot as a gleed
and your options are a
the balrogs whip
be
the silmaril that Baron and Lutheran
took from the iron crown of morgoth
see the ring that isildura cut from
sauron's finger
all day
Frodo's ring star sting sorry
so it's the balrog's whip
that Baron and luthien took from the
iron crown of morgoth the Ring the
isildura cut from sauron's finger and of
course Frodo's famous sword sting sting
as it was called ladies it's over to you
[Music]
foreign
my thoughts are divided
what an awful place
oh and it went for a which is the
balrogs whip Tom
so only leaves too yeah
yeah cheers on it so you can either
choose the ring that cut is still deals
uh the ring that car is still just cut
from Sirens the ring that isn't doing
okay
sting you can both choose the same one
ladies we've got nothing else to do
I'll go with the ring same
wrote that the ring he cut from sauron's
finger was hot when he first took it hot
as a gleed and my hand was scorched so
that I doubt if ever again I shall be
free of the pain of it that's what he
said it was hot hot as a gleed okay
everything you touch something hot just
say that oh it's like a glue oh take
that Coast pie out the oven is as hot as
a Glade oh I can't put that in my mouth
okay ladies here's another question for
you you'll enjoy this one which of these
things is not not made of wood of the
fair tree Le bethron beloved of the
woodrites of Gondor which is not me from
that word so three of them are going to
be made of that wood one of them's not
and here we go the casket carrying the
crown of aragons Coronation this be the
Steve's given by faramir to Frodo and
Sam see the chair of the Stuart denethor
or D the hammock of Galadriel one of
those is not made of very beloved it
seems wood ornate Lovely World from the
fair tree lebethron I'm gonna sing the
theme tune to uh sings uh ski Sunday
hello
I'm gonna say the staves the states
okay and Sheila you can also say the
staves of course or you could say
something else
the casket the chair the hammock or of
course the staves what wasn't me over
the chair the chair of the steward
dinosaur
is made of stone black and unadorned
fantastic work both the two of you since
that quiz was very hard in fact Billy
and I Billy specifically but Billy said
before the quiz he said these questions
are far too hard we no one can answer
these so the fact that you guys hug in
there and did your best congratulations
to the two of you Johnny Clues lost the
place today and no one could answer
those questions and you ladies did
absolutely fantastic Sheila tell tell
Sheila what's this one Dom well Sheila
you've won something unknown and random
from the uh friendship onion merchandise
we'll send the two of you something for
being involved in the show we're not
sure what it is probably I would think
katisha since they just fit so
beautifully I love the t-shirts you'll
agree yeah you can get them from the
friendship onionpodcast.com exactly well
thank you very much for coming on the
short review
traditionally yeah we allow both the
quiz people to ask us a question if
they'd like to you guys don't have to
but if you had a burning Lord of the
Rings question is there anything in
particularly
it might be about Billy's socks I'd
forgotten all about that to be honest
right Ali is there anything you're like
oh I've always wanted to ask them
something or Johnny Clues well I was
trying to think about things I asked my
friends that I want to know about them
and so I'd love to know how you guys
take your coffee
I take my uh black sometimes with a
little and I would say a quarter of a
teaspoon of
honey
just like that I take a few ways to be
honest I love coffee alley I really I'm
I'm slightly obsessed by you in fact my
wife was getting me a coffee yesterday
and I wrote him and says oh get get me a
latte and then I roll back and I said no
make out an Americano and in my head I
know how I take everything but she put
milk in my Americano I don't put milk in
my Americano I put half a sugar in my
Americano I take a latte as it comes and
if I'm in a Dana I'll take their drip
coffee with some a half and half
uh it's a lovely question I used to like
coffee in fact during the covid lockdown
I wasn't drinking any coffee and Billy
said you should try coffee it's a lovely
way to start your day and I tried it and
it was lovely and I love the buzz and
since then my buddies got used to it and
now I need to drink kind of six to eight
cups of coffee together 68
628. so I don't really bother with
coffee anymore hey Ali how do you like
your coffee and Sheila do you drink
coffee as well I usually drink mine
black yeah
I don't drink any coffee even though I'm
from Portland
fries your adrenal glands I think it's
very good for you and Sheila do you have
a burning question or not necessarily
um I have a riddle for you guys
okay
um so I created this one a while ago
um here we go there are two kinds of
shells the first keeps hidden inside it
little green balls the second you need
lots of if you have a nasty fall
put side by side these shells create an
entertaining Duo but really anyone can
make this with the simple recording
studio now did you say shells like
seashells or did you say shelves like in
a Cupboard
like a seashell
okay so there are two green shell
green bulge was it
green and red balls just green I think
just green and then the other one you
need a lot of it if you have a fall
put them together and they are what
put side by side these shells create an
entertaining Duo
and attaining Duo
side by side
and then what you get but you could make
them
if you stick them in a recording studio
I feel like it's something to do with us
were you well us if you put us together
in a recording studio we make something
interesting why are we shells and
exactly but also side by side we make a
entertaining Jewels sending you but why
shells
I don't have green balls right
um
You need a lot if you fall you need a
lot yes I have something to do with like
bandages or needle it does it like a
plaster yeah
is it plaster of Paris like no clusters
plasters like Band-Aids so maybe they
call it something different in the
states
Band-Aids is it so if you fall over you
need somebody
to break a bone you need bandages a
stooky we call it what's a sticky called
in America what a bandage no like when
you get you break a leg oh a plaster
cast plastic I figured it out what how
do you figure it out okay Ally you guys
are on the right track okay so can we
keep going for a minute I think so give
us a little bit of a clue either Ali or
she'll so
but how does it all link together
shell first part think of vegetables of
course think of vegetables green shampoo
green pea green peas peace Give Peace a
chance peace peace peace
are you just saying peas over and over
again yeah yeah why don't you get green
circle so that's a that's a green piece
green peas oh Green Peace So the word
peace and live it
there was a tenuous link there it's
something to do with
plasters or bandages
oh cast the cast of The Castle the cast
of the Friendship onion if you put two
people together they become a cast
if you're doing Waiting for God though
but indeed
green peas peace peace what are peas
found in pods
podcast podcast
let's go we've got it podcast
how's that
yeah
sorry to scream now nice to screaming
again that that you've got a mind you're
a riddle uh Creator Sheila
I like to make things rhyme yeah wow
well that's a poet as well then yeah it
is yeah well ladies it's been lovely
having you on
please give your details to our
illustrious uh producers and
we'll try and send you something in the
mail
but thanks for um that you're gonna cry
then I was quite upset that they're
leaving I like ladies Ali and Sheila
fantastic lots of love to you have a
great rest of the day
in Tennessee bye-bye bye friends bye
well what a wonderful quiz William I
loved it it's good having the quiz back
let's do it more
[Music]
to close out the show we love it when
you send us a song that you think is
funky and with that in mind let's check
to see if a song sensor was from
Jennifer in Sweden it's funky for you
I am a visitor of my own Universe I am
an alien in my unconsciousness
[Music]
[Music]
all right
wow that was fantastic well they called
them Yo they're called thumpasaurus
sorry and that was the song alien
Jennifer said the song I want to rate is
want uterate is alien by thumposaurus
I've only recently found them out so I
don't really know too much about them
but they are truly talented amazing
musicians who choose to have fun and do
some weird funky stuff if you like the
song they have two albums out which I
highly recommend dedicating an hour of
your day to listen to it is an
experience I will definitely be checking
those guys out on the way home
definitely checking out thumpasaurus and
how funky were they for you don't they
where they on honored a scale of not
very funky Brahms to Funky purple is
most Prince
that was the TomTom Club that's funky I
know I'm gonna say because you can't get
any more real funky than than that
really I'm gonna say Funkadelic doing
something really funky on the stage with
a funky crowd that's almost the most
funky you can get pretty funky hey send
in your recommendations for a song that
you think is funky to us at the
Friendship onion keep in mind you can
rate review And subscribe to our podcast
it really much it really much helps us
out it much only helps the time it very
much helps us out thumpasaurus if you
want to get hold of any of the merch
that's at the frenchmanionpodcast.com
and also send us your voicemails
speakpape.com forward slash the
Friendship onion and guys guess what
we'll see you next week see ya Turtles
[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your boy stuff
baby you're my Pearl